si l'histoire d'un couple de parents ils
ont quatre enfants et ils trouvent que
les enfants ou quelque chose quelque
chose de pas normal
je les vois qu'ils sont paulo je me
disais qu'on brûle un nuage mais
vraiment intense
ce soir on va vous lancer sur une piste
inquiétante avec un nouveau mot qu'on a
appris dans notre enquête manganèse ça
c'est des jeux considérés élevé la
petite clinique cl
et puis même gentil sont là et s'il y
avait quelque chose dans l'eau ça vous
dérange on me parle de l'eau aussi dans
sa et demain ou trop ses enfants leur
ont des problèmes d'apprentissage avec
nos équipes surprises
on s'est dit sud en se regardant dadié
un hôtel donc comme nous ont comme ça
ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête j'ai tout a été fait
de campagne puis j'aime la campagne
j'aime le 15 la béatitude que la
campagne vient apporter que ce soit d'un
écureuil qui voit un arbre que ce soit
une bonne carotte que tu accueilli dans
ton jardin la gestion la fierté que tous
deux et j'ai fait ce au pij il donne un
message la cure coup c'est mes enfants
trouvent le faire c'était trouver un
endroit où scama du moisi hors de la
ville c'était la grande valeur
[Musique]
oh
on a jusqu à arrêter les animaux on est
jusqu'à arrêter la ferme est que
d'enfants qui égayaient la vie de nos
enfants qui égayaient notre vie la
famille roy et betty 6-2 puis 16 au fil
des années il est devenu évident que les
enfants étaient atteints d'un mal
sournois
nous avons suivi la quête de ses parents
pour comprendre ce qui se passe je sais
qu'ils ont perdu beaucoup
puis je sème impôts si on doit être
capable de rattraper ce qui a été bien
dit je suis bon c'est pas dit que la
seule façon d aider c2d sortir de cet
environnement toxique m'appelle gabriel
la teom
je m'appelle les lie je m'appelle lien
[Musique]
on
c'est pas ça des fois qu'ils sont
pauvres je me dis qu'on a quand même un
nuage mais vraiment intense où qu'ils
soient ça nous vraiment là-dessus qu'on
s'y c'est en regardant les perfectionner
dans toutes la même marque que c'était
un an dans six étaient jamais un gain de
mamie avec l'information pour peut mener
à la plus d'information menées et l
allemagne et pologne ont toutes des
troubles de mémoire
ketty a dû quitter son job éducatrice en
garderie david travaille comme analyste
programmeur chez bombardier produits
récréatifs
les enfants ont toujours été au centre
de leur vie leur médecin de famille le
docteur denis laflamme les connais
depuis des années qu en conviant le
dossier pour l'avoir visé assez bien
récemment c'est assez touchants il ya
plusieurs éléments qu'on trouve au
niveau de l'apprentissage chez des
quatre enfants les quatre enfants
d'après moi sont touchés il y en a deux
qui sont touchés de façon peut-être un
peu plus marqué nous avons consulté les
évaluations d'experts
les buts et scolaire les notes des
parents les monts des chiffres qui
témoignent des difficultés des quatre
enfants nelly est en 5e année du
primaire
mais selon les professionnels elle n'a
toujours pas acquis des notions de
deuxième année dans un devoir elle est
incapable de répondre à la majorité des
questions
aurais tu aimé vivre un noël d'autrefois
non il n'y a rien à dire
et en plus évident et m gabriel a subi
un traumatisme crânien lorsqu'il était
bébé mais son médecin n'a jamais cru que
la commotion pouvait à elle seule
expliquer ces difficultés il a 16 ans et
des acquis de 3ème année du primaire
liam a repris sa 2e année selon ses
enseignants il a de la difficulté à
comprendre la matière et à appliquer les
notions apprises
il semble oublier ce qu'il a appris il
est aujourd'hui en 2d des rangs
[Musique]
noah le petit dernier est en 2e année
selon un rapport d'évaluation en
orthophonie les capacités liées à
l'attention et la concentration pourrait
être investigués chez cet enfant quatre
enfants d'une même famille qui sont à
terre pour la chercheure de
sainte-justine maryse bouchard
il pourrait être intoxiqué oui ah ça
c'est des niveaux qui sont très très
très élevé ça ressemble à des niveaux
qu'on observe chez des personnes qui
sont intoxiqués ils de façon clinique
qui manifestent des symptômes très fort
le intoxiquée mais à quoi il a fallu des
mois des années pour trouver une piste
au mois de mai il y avait tellement
d'intervenants au moins 2 tab
je me suis en internat il y avait le
neuro il y avait le niveau psychologique
des 1 200 il y avait la dige l'ady gil
end a comme son scanner il y avait un
autre fan d'une orthophoniste qui avait
intérêt à ce que des lots
il y avait là pis s'ils veulent en à
face du petit louis plusieurs
évaluations de plusieurs professionnels
mais aucun est capable de poser un
diagnostic clair mais c'est vraiment
dans le domaine de l'apprentissage
l'aspect visuel ces choses là même au
point de vue vision là deschamps
périphériques et plusieurs éléments que
l'on retrouve chez les enfants puis qui
leur nuise au niveau académique de façon
importante
je pense qu'ils ont certains difficultés
à percevoir l'information a capté
l'information l'enregistrer autant au
point de vue de la mémoire que au point
de visio spatiales du site qui vont
avoir des difficultés
donc les domaines cognitifs sont sont
touchés de façon importante
en l'absence de diagnostic cathy et
david cherche de leur côté comprendre ce
qui se passe devient une obsession
c'est une alimentation s'étudier ci
dessus il ya peut-être quelque chose
d'environnement autour de nous on
arrêtait tout ce qui est sucre additifs
colorants ogm au nom en ville le gluten
sans réponse sans ressources est à bout
david songe à suivre les conseils des
enseignants et à médicamenté ses enfants
mais ils n'ont toujours pas de
diagnostic
ils ne sont pas autiste ils ne sont pas
tdah ils ne sont pas disposées son petit
praxis l'ex ids à ce que toutes les
villes
ils sont pauvres ok ils sont aucunement
dans aucune de ces branches l'eau à
l'hiver 2016 suivant les conseils d'une
naturopathe cathy d'un homme détoxifiant
de métaux l'eau aux quatre enfants
pendant quelques semaines
elle est convaincue que cela les a aidés
les cats tout les cas et qu'à tout
conscient ça a pris un mois là mais
enfin tu as toute l'eau c'est un beau de
voir parce que le rêve et la déduction
là il nous parlait et nous donner leurs
impressions c'était merveilleux
le on regarde la boîte on y trouvait de
bon lit c'est quoi ça fait déjà ça
enlève les métaux lourds
le roi des métaux vacallo lui il y ait
percé et est allée tout c'est mon amour
que toute trouvée pour vérifier cette
hypothèse qui cherchent des réponses sur
internet un test de cheveux pourrait
révéler la présence de métaux dans
l'organisme
bon bah oui vraiment cette année là à
dessein de le réparer s'est dit je vois
pas de l'aromatique haynes le joue à
leurs frais douteuses de sa voix douce à
manger en avoir le coeur net mais à
faire quelque chose ou pour trois
semaines après on a eu les résultats
donc comment vous avez réagi je me
demandais c'était quoi du manganèse la
plus longue ligne
selon mot révèlent une concentration
nettement élevée de manganèse
je laisse avoir découvert parce que il y
avait toutes les toutes les sortes de
mets ton toutes les affaires qui avait
des cheveux mais je voyais avec le or
mon statut et or ap normal ok je regarde
que ça veut dire magana et ckoi
manganèse vos voisins ternaire puis il
me rappelle après eddy hachoir je fais
des recherches plus poussées
[Musique]
david n'avait aucune idée où ses
recherches sur le manganèse allait le
mener
après la pause notre enquête se poursuit
à act une vo et on va les faire analyser
l'eau des résidents en avril 2018 katif
et analyser les cheveux de deux des
enfants
six mois plus tard les résultats en mai
david et elles se rendent chez leur
médecin de famille sont arrivés très
bien informé de droit des loques
leurs données étaient probants depuis ce
moment là il fallait moi je pense qu'il
fallait les écouter il y avait déjà un
test capillaire qui montrait un père
sans thil qui est en haut du 97ème peut
ressentir pour le manganèse
il y avait déjà été voir un médecin je
pense dans une clinique de sang rendez
vous qui avait déjà presque une première
prise de sang donc l on voyait que dans
ce sens le manganèse été élevé puis donc
que je peux pour vraiment mettre sans
doute
l'onu les problèmes premiers résultats
pendant 7 mondiaux on a aussi dans ce
sens et demain outre aux là il ya
vraiment un problème
là c'est les six personnes
du manganèse dansant on en a tous il
s'agit d'un minéral essentiel à la vie
qui est présent dans l'air le sol l'eau
et dans certains aliments
normalement le corps humain est bien
équipé pour éliminer le surplus mais le
manganèse peut aussi être neurotoxiques
et les bébés seraient particulièrement
vulnérables
nous avons présenté des résultats
sanguins de la famille roy au professeur
maryse bouchard qui a fait des
découvertes importantes sur le manganèse
la femme et se retrouve à des
concentrations qui sont à peu près ici
sur ma figure donc c'est vraiment les
concentrations qui sont de loin plus
élevé que ce qu'on voit parce qu'en fait
et c'est la ligne c'est la moyenne
puisque c'est là la variabilité jusqu'au
95% les plus élevés donc ça c'est déjà
considéré élevé la petite ligne missiles
et puis même ajouté sont liées à la
famille à peu près tous les membres de
la famille ont des concentrations
commander of de charlotte littéralement
en 2007 maryse bouchard a étudié 362
enfants du primaire de huit
municipalités du québec dont les
aqueducs municipaux s'approvisionnent
dans les eaux souterraines
sincèrement j'étais surprise oui on
était dans des niveaux qui est exposé
d'être sécuritaire selon les
connaissances du monde et pourtant et
pourtant nous ce qu'on a vu c'est des
diminutions de qi de l'ordre de six
points entre les enfants les plus
exposés les moins exposées et on a vu
aussi donc d atteinte chez les enfants
au niveau 2
mémoire puis au niveau de la tension
puis un petit peu aussi au niveau des de
la dextérité manuelle tous ceux en lien
avec l'exposition manganèse via l'eau
potable dans ses recherches sur le
terrain plus il y avait de manganèse
dans l'eau du robinet plus les enfants
étaient touchés du côté de la famille
roy les retards scolaires des quatre
enfants chacune une personne qui nous
aurait coûté normalement elle aucun
temps de trop comme ça ça peut provenir
aussi d'autant la consommation d'eau
péril ajoutent le lire sur notre machine
doperait au québec en zone rurale chaque
propriétaire depuis est responsable de
la qualité de son eau ou en achetant la
maison en 2003 david a fait tester l'eau
de son puits
à l'époque les résultats ne lui disait
rien personne ne se souciait des dangers
possibles du manganèse pour la santé le
taux de manganèse était pourtant
quatorze fois plus élevé que la valeur
guide esthétique tv s'en est rendu
compte des années plus tard
en fouillant dans son dossier et sur
internet
une fois que j'y suis allé voir les
énormes sur le santé canada et puis si
la norme état de 0.05 mg par litre et je
vous laisse mon papier qu'on abaisse
0.60 10 milliards par année comme pas
mal
il n'existe pas de norme au québec liées
aux mandats maire mais il ya une valeur
dite esthétique de 0,05 milligramme par
litre esthétique parce que le manganèse
peut tacher les vêtements la baignoire
ou les vielles a montré notre système de
traitement donc pour corriger ce
problème et la dureté de son nom d'un v
droit afin d'installer un système de
filtration plus sophistiqués en 2007 et
nous par précaution on a un fils
prennent d'entrée deuxième filtre pour
lui des fameuses bout il y a deux ans et
a constaté qu'il y avait du manganèse au
robinet j'ai appelé la compagnie mère de
la machine de l'île sont venus
directement faire détester si ça passait
au travail
gabrielli c'est des gros buveurs d'eau
raison bus vélo c'était effroyable 27-20
pouvait boire dix à douze bateaux par
jour
hormis n'est bien entendu d'un tas
les deux enfants qui vivaient beaucoup
d'eau sont les plus atteints il était
possible de savoir pendant combien de
temps les enfants bu de l'eau riche en
manganèse
il est même possible que cela remonte à
la grossesse de cathy ces enfants là on
les problèmes d'apprentissage à l'école
moi je suis pas surprise dans son étude
la chercheuse maryse bouchard a tenté de
mesurer l'impact du manganèse sur le
cerveau des enfants qu'on a vraiment
finement ajusté pour toutes les
variables qui sont d'importantes
puissent s'adonner quand même des
résultats ont envoyé une association
très forte entre la concentration de
manganèse dans l'eau et le capacity que
les capacités cognitives des enfants
alors le lien vous diriez le lien les
possibles fortement pesé il est
fortement plausible si on se met dans le
contexte du reste des connaissances
scientifiques qu'on a on sait que le
manganèse et neurotoxiques la toxicité
du manganèse est connu depuis plus de
100 ans des travailleurs exposés à des
poussières de manganèse développent des
problèmes neuro dégénératifs locaux
spéculent sur son manque de poésie ni ce
documentaire sud-africain exposé l'état
de travailleurs d'une mine de manganèse
ça me les symptômes du manga nisme
ressemblent à ceux du parkinson
il s'agit là d'une intoxication par des
poussières mais de récentes recherches
suggèrent qu'une intoxication par l'eau
potable seraient aussi possibles
le docteur louis patry du chum estime
que les bébés et les jeunes enfants sont
particulièrement à risque
des études en fait quand à travers le
monde sont assez vont quand même dans la
même direction et il n'est pas toujours
parfaite mais quand on regarde
l'ensemble des études on s'aperçoit que
le manganèse a un rôle important est
qu'un excellent lyonnaise pourrait
affecter le développement du système
nerveux de l'enfant à la suite de sa
rencontre avec les membres de la famille
roy le docteur patrie a tout de suite
alerté la direction de la santé publique
après avoir analysé le dossier elle
conclut qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une menace
à la santé de la population
elle considère que pour l'instant la
famille roy est un cas isolé
est ce que le problème plus important
est ce que le problème pourrait toucher
par exemple seront vieux manganèse plus
d'enfants qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
les études qui ont été faites en toc par
le docteur rogers suffisamment
intéressant pour se dire qu'il faut
aller encore un peu plus loin dans ce
avec cette problématique
nous avons voulu savoir si d'autres
citoyens d'acton vale était touché
[Musique]
oui bonjour
welch est désolé
[Musique]
parfaitement
nous on veut savoir si audi manganèse un
peu trop vous tient au courant de ce
contre eux ok on va aller chez le voisin
[Musique]
bouazo ça vous dérange on vient prendre
de l'eau jamie jay pole parce que ça
fait des années de rester ce que tu es
mon père au dessus et vous brisez l'eau
du robinet c'est un projet auquel cas on
va vous dire vous tenir au courant l
analyse
[Musique]
jean science
alors on va aller à 28 on connaît
lodetti normand dupuis ne bois pas l'eau
du robinet il nous amène à la source où
il va chercher son nom alors l'eau du
robinet vous la prenez pour la cuisson
c'est ça puis l'eau de source
ça c'est de l'eau que vous buvez tous
les jours depuis des années mais les
gens autour de chez vous le plus à la
campagne ce qui sont soucieuses qui sont
inquiets c'est tout le sens du progrès
ces descentes
vraiment ça d'en parler comme de l'eau à
savoir que ce que ça faisait pour une
personne évidemment ghana
vous en aviez pas d'idées
le père de david roy habite au centre
ville d'acton verne
ça c'est de l'eau avec de la vie oui ok
alors est-ce que vous pensez que les
bonnes nous est fatale pour lui des deux
alors là on va prendre un échantillon de
l'eau de la ville pour la question voir
si intimement l'aise
c'était ma demande et après tu as vendu
loge et à paul a fait tester on va faire
pour vous les voici en quoi c'est un
impôt bien tant mieux
les bains il ya des matins entre la
toile est le fondateur de savate brin ya
des couches harris et rouge brique
des fois c'est noir c'est quelqu'un qui
attendent leur poule audrey c'est ce qui
arrive c'est le sais pas pourquoi on se
pose des questions là on est dans l ain
afin d'imposer question c'est pas juste
de pointer du doigt à quelqu'un de cette
sa faute
faux faux trouver il faut trouver mais
qui cherche la direction de la santé
publique a refusé de nous donner une
entrevue à la caméra elle a répondu à
nos questions dans un courriel pour elle
seuls les travailleurs de l'acier qui
respire des poussières de manganèse
peuvent être intoxiqué
même si la santé publique reconnaît la
vulnérabilité des nourrissons elle juge
que le lien entre le manganèse et le
développement neurologique des enfants
n'est pas encore établie avec certitude
dans sa réponse l'organisme ne s'est pas
les études de maryse bouchard
il se réfère à plusieurs recherches dont
une étude américaine financée par un
groupe de lobbyistes qui fait pression
pour un assouplissement des normes
entourant le manganèse
ben moi d'un point de vue de
spécialistes en santé environnementale
c'est sûr et certain que si on trouve un
endroit un puits donc une famille une
maison qui est des concentrations très
élevées
il ya des chances plus élevé que co
hasard que les voisins aussi à des
concentrations élevées
il me semble qu'il devrait il ya quelque
chose là une action communautaire qui
devrait être réalisé
dans la suite de notre enquête vous
allez voir que la famille roy n'est pas
la seule à s'inquiéter du manganèse
[Musique]
nous avons pris des échantillons d'eau
au puits privés et au robinet chez
treize citoyens d'acton vale
nous avons suivi le protocole à la
lettre et fait faire les analyses par un
laboratoire accrédité par le
gouvernement le taux de manganèse au
puis chez les rois n'a jamais été aussi
élevé 1,1 milligramme par litre
c'est dix fois la nouvelle valeur santé
proposée par santé canada
mais le plus important c'est qu'il n'y a
plus de manganèse au robinet
grâce à leur nouveau filtre le voisin
d'en face à une concentration deux fois
trop élevé et lui il n'a pas de filtre
chez normand depuis le tour et de 0,18
mg par litre
plutôt que le 0,12 recommandé il n'y
avait pas de manganèse ni aux puits ni
au robinet chez tous les autres que nous
avons testé l'eau que ces gens boivent
n'étaient pas contaminés au manganèse au
moment où nous avons fait les tests
l'histoire aurait pu se terminer ici
mais au contraire
le mystère s'épaissit
dans le cadre de notre enquête
vingt-cinq personnes ont accepté de
faire un test sanguin
même s'il n'y avait pas de manganèse
dans l'eau au moment de notre test
seize d'entre eux ont un taux de
manganèse dans cent plus élevé que la
normale qui est entre 140 et 270 mg
parle et vous vous avez fait des tests
de st
prenons en terre
qu'est ce que c'est très 80's que votre
positionnement gagnent tous les deux
vous avez des concentrations
anormalement élevé pourquoi
hun sen
j'ai passé des tests des tests sanguins
et puis la normale ces deux le maximum
ses 270 de manganèse
j'ai 460 puis j'y joue de la ville il ya
quelque chose de pas normal c'est quand
même quelque chose qui me dit que la
population est exposée à du manganèse et
probablement si c'est dans une si ses
proches et du travail anses des
opérations générales
la source principale est probablement
l'eau
de son côté la direction de la santé
publique croit qu'il est impossible
d'être intoxiqué au manganèse en buvant
de l'eau selon elle d'autres facteurs
peuvent influencer un taux élevé de
manganèse dansant la génétique des
problèmes de foie et l'alimentation
mais ce possible que les seize personnes
d'actes nouvelle que nous avons trouvé
qui ont des taux élevés de manganèse
dansant est des liens génétiques est
tous des problèmes de foie
est-ce que l'alimentation peut expliquer
ces taux élevés selon moi c'est pas une
ça ne peut pas être la chose parce que
sinon on aurait des codes rapporté
d'intoxication alimentaire au manganèse
puis à l'heure actuelle chez des
individus en santé oms de poche ce genre
de qualité rapporte vous parlez au
québec au canada
diététicienne au département de
nutrition de l'université de montréal
geneviève mayotte a été consulté par la
direction de la santé publique dans le
dossier de la famille roy pour savoir
quelles étaient les sources alimentaires
de manganèse pour savoir s'il y avait
une intoxication potentiel violent
alimentation donc oui ils m'ont contacté
à cette échelle
qu'est ce que vous leur avez dit je
l'aurais dit j'aurais répondu là quelque
chose qui avoue c'est à dire que au
niveau de l'alimentation yoopa
d'intoxication possible manganèse
seulement en consommant des aliments qui
contiennent du manganèse
la situation de la famille roy a suscité
une rencontre entre le ministère de
l'environnement
la direction de la santé publique leur
médecin de famille le docteur patrie et
le maire d'acton vert à la suite de
cette rencontre la municipalité a fait
analyser l'eau de puits de cinq
résidences l'eau des cinq puis avait des
teneur très élevée en manganèse dont un
qui avait un taux huit fois plus élevé
que la valeur santé une maison avait
même une teneur non conforme de
manganèse au robinet en juillet dernier
la ville d'acton a émis un communiqué
pour rassurer ses citoyens à propos du
manganèse dans l'eau de la ville en 2018
aucun résultat n'excède la nouvelle
recommandation santé de santé canada de
0,12 mg par litre
présentement et pendant deuxièmement des
tests contact sur le magasin tout les
jours chez ma bus portes à tous les
jours il était sur le magasin ce qui est
fait on est en dessous du nord présente
même pas nos facs ont été en deçà des
normes esthétiques
[Musique]
quand nous avons fait tester l'eau chez
le père de david dont la résidence est
alimenté par l'aqueduc municipal
il n'y avait pas de manganèse mais trois
semaines plus tard vu la couleur de
l'eau il a fait faire une deuxième
analyse et obtenu un résultat différent
0,1 7 8 mg par litre
un peu plus que la valeur santé de 0,1 2
mg parler selon la ville ce résultat est
peut être due à l'opération de rinçage
du réseau qui se tenait ce jour là
sauf que dans leurs relevés quotidiens
ce dépassement n'apparaît pas décevant
katia lamothe et sa famille habitent au
coeur d'athènes vers une maison
desservies par l'aqueduc municipal
ils boivent de l'eau embouteillée katia
utilisent l'eau du robinet uniquement
pour la cuisson les jus et le jello
eu david qui nous a contacté pour nous
et qu'il y avait toute la famille avec
du magam aise dans son ca puis le centre
était un petit peu dans tête parce qu'il
m'a ganay ce jour dans les opus naomi a
eu un ostéosarcome un cancer des os x
samedi amy a mijoté dans ma tête j'ai
essayé de m'enlever de la tête ça
revenait toujours fait que j'ai décidé
de faire passer naomi en premier mais
qu'est ce que c'est à dire le résultat
steak b et c soit est à 400 cucq cloche
490 je pense pas qu'ils étaient élevés
fait que dès qu'on ne se soit passé
toutes les 3g à challes et mon médecin
de famille un petit peu pour avoir les
tests nous aussi pire finalement nelly
capte avec un taux de mahdia nice trop
élevé moi je suis la pire l'an de
l'icapp sa fille naomi est en rémission
ses médecins l'ont rassuré le taux de
manganèse dans son sang n'est pas en
cause
contrairement aux enfants de la famille
roy naomi et kim n'ont pas de problèmes
d'apprentissage
vous avez un code par exemple 10 20 ou
30 personnes dans une région donnée qui
ont des surcharges en manganèse alors
pourquoi est ce que des sources qui
peuvent l'expliquer parce que les sourds
sont au niveau hydrique est ce qu'ils
proviennent à un moment donné ce qui
pourrait provenir d'une usine qui est
pas très loin il ya des déchets qui sont
émis sur je ne sais pas mais
effectivement il ya un roe de ce côté là
à la fois santé publique et
environnement
permet les citoyens d'actes nouvelle
chez qui on a détecté une forte
concentration de manganèse d'un sens la
moitié s'approvisionne par des puits
privés
au québec les grandes villes s'alimente
dans les eaux de surface les rivières
les lacs le fleuve les eaux souterraines
alimente 20% de la population du québec
pour mieux connaître la qualité de ses
eaux
le ministère de l'environnement a lancé
en 2009 une campagne de prélèvements sur
l'ensemble du territoire les points
jaunes représentent les échantillons ou
les teneur en manganèse dépasse la
valeur santé les points rouges ce qui
dépasse trois fois la valeur santé selon
notre analyse des résultats
préliminaires jusqu'à 24% des
échantillons dépasse la valeur santé
selon le ministère de l'environnement
cent soixante six villes et villages
approvisionner en eau souterraine
n'applique aucun traitement avant sa
distribution
nous avons cherché ce qui a pu
contaminer le puits de la famille roy la
montérégie est une région où l'on
retrouve de fortes concentrations
naturel de manganèse dans le sol ce
métal peut se dissoudre atteindre la
nappe phréatique et se retrouver dans
des puits mais ce possible que la cause
ne soit pas naturel des rejets
industriels des activités minières et
des résidus de site d'enfouissement
peuvent être des sources de
contamination selon santé canada
à 600 mètres de leur maison trône depuis
une immense carrière de chaux et de
béton
le propriétaire a reçu trois amants du
ministère de l'environnement au cours
des deux dernières années pour
entreposage illégal de bouts de métal et
d'autres déchets et se défend en disant
qu'il n'y a aucun lien entre ces amendes
et le manganèse
sur le même site des citoyens nous ont
raconté que dans les années 50 il y
avait un dépotoir
aujourd'hui personne ne peut nous dire
s'il a été décontaminés ou pas
nous avons pris un échantillon d'eau
d'une rigole qui coule sur le terrain de
la carrière
résultat l'eau à bendtner six fois plus
élevé en manganèse que la valeur santé
nous avons découvert au coeur d'athènes
vers des terres où s'amoncellent des
amas de débris au fil des ans des
propriétaires ont reçu des avis de non
conformité pour y avoir entreposé du
béton de la spat et de la ferraille sur
ce terrain à 200 mètres de la maison de
davet de voix nous avons prélevé un
échantillon d'une flaque d'eau la
concentration manganèse est 20 fois plus
élevée que la valeur santé
[Musique]
si on pense qu'il ya un lien entre le
manganèse dans l'eau
le manganèse dans le sang et les
troubles cognitifs
mais il faut aussi trouver
une solution ou la cause pour prévenir
je pense ça fait partie de la médecine
sont ya un problème fois plus mal il
regarder ce qu'on appelle une
surveillance active
si vous attendez d'avoir toutes les
études épidémiologiques avant d'agir là
il va se passer beaucoup de temps avant
qu'on puisse avoir des rues d'och ont
effectivement l'incertitude
[Musique]
on le sait il y à du manganèse beaucoup
de manganèse dans l'eau à certains
endroits au québec
et pourtant toujours aucune
réglementation la suite de notre enquête
dans un instant le ministère de
l'environnement c'est finalement déplacé
nous avons croisé par hasard une équipe
venue prendre des échantillons d'eau
chez les rois ce jour là cette équipe a
aussi fait des prélèvements d'eau chez
des voisins et à la carrière d'acteur
le ministère de l'environnement confirme
que le taux de manganèse au puits de la
famille roy dépasse la valeur santé mais
il conclut que cette contamination est
liée au teneur naturelle dans les sols
de la région toutes les dégâts c'est la
déco remis dans les normes
de plus deux continents qui était au
niveau la nappe de gaz
le maire d'actes une ville venait de
recevoir le rapport d' analyse du
ministère de l'environnement qui conclut
que ni l'ancien site d'enfouissement ni
la carrière ont contaminé les eaux
souterraines
on a vérifié bon on le met sa
l'environnement vérifier y aucune cause
à effet ils ont fait ayant faisait la
nappe est longue et rich lee ont fait
des analyses
on y ajoute au ya donc ne confirme que
la présence magana ce qui dans l'île fût
d'adressé et le naturellement alors et
la carrière aucun effet sur la nappe
phréatique honnêtement qu'est ce qu'on
fait exactement aux comptes le nom et
apollo donc vous référer à la liste à
l'environnement et moins capable de vous
exactement ce qu'est ce qu'on fait au
niveau des deux secondes pour en savoir
plus sur les analyses nous avons demandé
ce rapport en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information au ministère de
l'environnement
notre demande date du 17 juillet dernier
nous n'avons encore rien reçu
le ministère a refusé de nous donner une
entrevue dans le cadre de cette enquête
[Musique]
non
pour la famille roy la saga continue
si les enfants avaient des diagnostics
clair il pourrait peut-être obtenir plus
d aide à l'école aujourd'hui destination
hôpital sainte-justine à montréal
la rencontre sera finalement décevante
toujours pas de diagnostic pour les
enfants mais bonne nouvelle le niveau de
manganèse dans le sens de tous les
membres de la famille est revenue à la
normale cet été car depuis 18 mois la
famille consomme de l'eau embouteillée
même si les niveaux en manganèse dans
l'eau du robinet était revenue à la
normale
comment se libérer de la peur
on disait que m'envoient quoi on va
peut-être voir on va peut-être bon les
enfants sur leur vrai jour le temps on
va peut-être voir un changement quelque
chose
mais s'il ya de quoi à moi honnêtement
si à peine perceptible je le vois pas je
pense que ça va peut-être prendre des
années je ne sais pas est-ce que serré
versée je sais pas y'a personne je pense
qu'il peut être quelqu'un qui peut se
prononcer là dessus si c'est réversible
ou pas je ne sais pas si ça va revenir
on est dans des eaux que de nos experts
n'a pu répondre à cette question
même s'il n'ya pas encore de lien causal
hors de tout doute entre le manganèse
dans l'eau et le développement
neurologique des enfants santé canada a
quand même jugé bon d'intervenir en mai
dernier il recommande pour la première
fois une valeur guide pour la santé dès
que j'ai vu les premiers résultats de
mes études
ces résultats qui était quand même assez
inquiétant ou petit pour la santé
publique
une des premières choses que j'ai fait
c'est moi de solliciter des rencontres
avec les auteurs en santé publique
pour lee et respectueux même si les
études sur les humains ne sont pas
encore concluante celle sur les animaux
le son en regardant l'ensemble des
données est bien
on trouvait qu'il y avait matière à
faire preuve de prudence en proposant
une critères de qualité mais plus strict
si on veut que ce qu'il y avait avant
lioness pq a recommandé au gouvernement
il y a deux ans de réglementer le
manganèse dans l'eau potable surtout
pour protéger les nourrissons
le gouvernement ne l'a pas encore fait
il ya clairement des municipalités qui
ont des concentrations beaucoup trop
élevé ou je pense que l'on ne vend dans
un territoire clair où il y aurait dû
avoir des mesures qui sont prises pour
diminuer les concentrations pour la
population tant qu'il n'y a pas de
recommandations et peu de normes les
municipalités n'ont pas l'obligation
d'agir c'est ça l'avantagé d'avoir une
norme ou d'un critères basés sur la
santé cette fois là plutôt que juste
esthétique c'est que ça va devenir
obligatoire en ce moment pour l'instant
le ministère de l'environnement se
contente de faire une mise en garde sur
son site web
lorsque la concentration en manganèse
dans l'eau est supérieur à 0,12 mg par
litre
la prudence est de mise pour les jeunes
enfants et plus particulièrement les
bébés alimenté au biberon
dans la mrc d'acton 30 % des élèves ont
des problèmes d'apprentissage selon le
ministère de l'éducation et ce en tenant
compte des facteurs socio-économiques la
moyenne au québec est de 19%
d'autres études sont nécessaires avant
d'affirmer que le manganèse présents
dans l'eau potable pourrait jouer un
rôle
alors il ya des enfants au québec qui
ont des problèmes d'apprentissage ce
serait à cause du manganèse
c'est possible par contre on manque de
données sur quels sont les
concentrations de manganèse dans l'eau
de toutes les municipalités du québec
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible que le manganèse contribuer aux
faiblesses d'apprentissage des enfants
dans les régions pour cette exclusion
non non pour moi c'est exclu si la note
appelant de ses voeux nous le guennec
pour ma part c'est exclu
il est maintenant reconnue
scientifiquement que le plomb et le
mercure sont néfastes sur le système
nerveux des enfants le manganèse
serait-elle donc le nouveau métal dont
il faudrait se méfier
[Musique]
depuis que maryse bouchard a sonné l
alarme sur les risques potentiels du
manganèse pour les enfants et s'est
écoulé neuf années des années cruciales
dont la vie de gabrielle liam nelly et
noah des années qui pèseront
possiblement sur leur avenir
je pense que tout parent aurait fait ce
qu'on a fait et même plus déployé
déployer toutes les ressources possibles
pour essayer de comprendre puis des 10
qui arrive à votre enfant c'est papier
jeu certaines jeu confiant que ça vaut
même profiter à d'autres ça fera pas des
ingénieurs cd étant vraiment qui a la
base je sais même pas ce qu'ils vont
être en capacité de dépenser leur
secondaire mais nous on veut miser
vraiment lourd au moins qu'ils soient
capables de fonctionner qui soit capable
de fonctionner en société va en même
temps aussi d'être capable de prendre
des décisions est capable d'avoir des
choix et d'avoir du discernement ce
qu'ils ont pour david et cathy ont mis
leur maison à vendre
même s'il n'ya plus de manganèse au
robinet même s'ils n'ont plus d'un cent
il souhaite partir les souvenirs sont
trop douloureux les conséquences trop
marre quand on se bat ici puis le faut
s'en aller parce que trouver quoi j'ai
peut-être sa soeur qui y est
on serait
on faisait un malade mais l'autre côté
si bien les différents patronymes ans
pour l'accepter comme ça c'est ce qui
fait quoi si con et nous c'est touchant
c'est inquiétant la fois compter sur
nous pour vous tenir au courant s'il ya
des développements dans cette histoire
en attendant je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir été là est revenu nous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]